albert breer here on the rich eisens
show from uh sports illustrated the mmqb
and uh one of our one of our favorites
joining us uh from
uh the metroplex where the owners are
meeting right now in the national
football league how you doing albert
i'm great i it's that's a really
interesting conversation you guys are
having on dion i'll say this
and i know money's coming into play and
everything else um but i just think this
is something i can add and i think you'd
probably echo this sure
the way
like when i was in nfl network for six
years
the way
peop the young players in the league
like beer dion gravitated
like and it was i would walk in with
that mic flag and they would say could
you say hello to prime for me could you
tell me
could could you could you could you make
sure that he knows that i'm doing this
because it's his name i mean it was
like it's unlike any i mean and and
there are a lot of great players that
were working there while we were there
together rich and it was just it was
unbelievable like the gravitational pull
that players had to dion and i think
that's a huge part of what was playing
out today right like it's just
i mean it's and i don't know what it is
because like it's amazing because like
these kids now are too young to have
actually seen him play no doubt
no question because he's speaking their
language now though albert he talks
their language now and if you're telling
a kid
who wants to make it to the nfl
and that's the goal and dion knows
that's the goal right and who would you
certainly if you're a defensive back who
would you want to be coached by more
right than this guy you know the crazy
thing about this is albert and brockman
knows this as well
and the the most surprised i am that
dion is coach of the year isn't the fact
that he's achieved it okay at all
the most surprised i have is because
this is a guy who when we first started
working together in the early aughts
would watch a football game and when
somebody did something stupid he would
scream cut him at the screen cut him you
know
like before he got back to the sidelines
he said
and that's a coach of the year now you
know you got to be patient you got to
you got to cajole you got to teach this
that's that's the most amazing thing you
know
about it yeah to me yeah it's crazy and
and i look like there's
i mean with you know some of these walls
being broken down um you know there's no
reason why
he can't like i mean again like you know
build the right sort of coaching staff
and create partnerships because of the
platform that he has and you know like
give kids opportunities that maybe they
can't get anywhere else you know what i
mean like at jackson state which is it's
unbelievable and and good for him
because
this is definitely
outside the box thinking and it's not
being kind of a prisoner to what the
norms of college football have been um
and he found something clearly because
you know that gravitational pull that we
talked about the kids have to him
personally is now you know absolutely in
play in the case of the number one
player in the country
going to you know an fcs hbcu school
albert breer senior nfl reporter the
mmqb
uh right here on the rich eisen show
from sports illustrated what's going on
uh on the conversation about this
saturday game between the raiders and
the covid 19 ravaged cleveland browns
organization
yeah i mean i you know generally this
meeting this december meeting um you
know in dallas and it's here every year
um is
sort of an update on things like where
are we going with the super bowl it's
setting things up for the the following
year's offseason and obviously like the
happenstance that we're here and you
have the outbreak with the rams um on
monday and tuesday now the outbreak with
the browns washington's got a rising
number of cases too
i think it's brought this to the
forefront and it's what everybody's been
talking about over the last two days
here
um you know what i can tell you rich
like
is that they're planning on going
forward with the game on saturday
and you know one of the issues that
they're going to have now is that
if they were to move it to like say
sunday or monday that probably wouldn't
do any good because
um the overwhelming number of cases in
the nfl this year when guys test in when
guys like test positive they're having
problems testing out like if you'll
notice if you go through all these cases
almost every one of um the player cases
the staff cases
these people have sat out for the full
10 days because they keep testing
positive so they have to go through the
full 10 days
so like you make the argument with the
browns if that's the case with these 15
guys and maybe the number rises over the
next couple of days
like what sense is it to move the game
to monday or tuesday when you're still
within that 10-day window so i think
that they're going to go forward with
the game as best they can
um and while that's going on here in
dallas
um the officials from the league office
basically informed you know the owners
and executives that they're discussing
significant changes to the kovid 19
protocols with the union now i think
everybody's viewing this as an
inflection point um and you know i i
think the
the feeling here is that
it's it's going to be difficult under
the current circumstances to get from
here to the middle of february and to
los angeles for the super bowl
under the current circumstances um
unaffected so like i i my sense is we we
will see some alterations to the kobe 19
protocols coming like what i mean for
again
because you could test positive
well after you through cdc rules and
guidelines that everybody has
uh uh you know uh followed since the
beginning of this pandemic you could
test positive long after you're no
longer symptomatic or considered to be
contagious um you know that's why many
people who travel abroad are stuck there
when they test positive
abroad because they're not allowed to
leave the country or come back in until
their test negative for many spots
around the world so that's in place for
somebody who might be vaccinated and has
a false positive so you get two
negatives and now you get to play uh but
if you're if you're if you are actually
positive it's impossible sometimes to to
to test twice in a row which is why if
this is for real with baker mayfield a
real positive he's out for saturday
that's going to be case kingdoms gig so
what what changes are you referring to
do you think with the policy here you
know i think there are three things that
we can that we can look for i'm not
saying they're all going to happen but
they've all at least been discussed
um you know the first one is
the idea that they could cut down um the
they could cut down the the waiting
periods that 10 day period maybe they
turn to five days
somehow altering that altering that said
that that waiting period would be
i think one piece of this that they're
that they will and have already
approached with the union and all this
stuff obviously needs to be discussed
with the union um the second thing is
that they could go into enhanced
protocols with all teams in the playoffs
which
um you know i think would require
meeting virtually right and this is
something that they actually warn teams
that this could happen and maybe it
happened before the playoffs but
um you're going back to even vaccinated
players wearing masks around facilities
and all that different stuff so that's
number two
and number three and this to me is
probably the most significant one if it
were to happen
because it would be i think a departure
from
where pro sports have been over the last
year and a half is that they could
incentivize players getting the booster
shot
by saying to them if you get the booster
shot we will no longer test you
regularly as long as you're asymptomatic
and that's the one to me like that
you know like i said like it's a pretty
it'd be a pretty major step in a
different direction than the one they've
been going in but i think maybe a step
towards
this sort of resignation that this isn't
going away and that everybody has to
learn to live with it and at least for
the people who have the booster shot and
have taken the steps to protect
themselves and others
like they shouldn't have to miss work
um if you know there's an asymptomatic
if if they're asymptomatic in other
words you're treating you're treating
symptoms you're not searching for the
virus
and you know like i know that sounds
like again like a a pivot for them and
it is
but that's the way a lot of workplaces
in america are right now you know rich
like you look at like most workplaces
they're not testing people regularly got
people get sick you know then there's
contact tracing and the rest of it
schools work that way they're not
testing kids regularly
um but you know when something comes up
they will test and so
um i that to me will be the most
significant one is if they decide to
create that incentive for players to get
booster shots and of course as i'm sure
you guys have read the other day um you
know on december 20 by december 27th
for staff to remain in tier one and tier
two they're actually going to have to um
they're gonna have to get booster shots
so that's that last part has to be
negotiated with the union but it could
happen all right albert breer here on
the rich eisen show um and there's
another item
um that i think
i'd like to bring to the attention of
fans it's been in the hopper and i
imagine uh it's getting voted on or it's
already been voted on
um that teams can virtually meet with
candidates
for a head coaching positions with two
weeks left in the regular season so
normally a coach would be you know
allowed to finish out a campaign um and
then that leads to as referred to the
the black monday the day after the
season where so many coaches get fired
is it possible that we might see some
interim head coaches uh toot sweet
because
uh leagues aren't going to be holding
virtual meetings that can get out and
and and and a coach that's already been
sitting there hears that
there's a you know a an interview for a
vacancy that hasn't occurred yet are we
going to see some firings in the next
couple weeks you think right around
christmas
i mean i think it's definitely possible
i think december 27th would be the day i
think that's the monday of week 16. so
um yeah i think that's certainly
possible where you know if you're a team
that's sitting there and you're saying
we're gonna fire him in two weeks why
don't we just get this process started
it could create a domino effect and you
know i think that's something certainly
to consider here where
let's just say for for argument's sake
um you know like the the raiders
they don't move on from rich versace but
they maybe like somehow make the
announcement all right like he's he's
not going to be the head coach going
forward they start interviewing people
does that motivate say chicago or
minnesota
or someone else to move on for their
coach because
they could be saying to themselves well
this other team is going to have a
two-week head start on us and they may
have something like borderline wrapped
up with a candidate that we may like
by the time we get to the finish line of
our season and we want to fire our coach
so i think it absolutely could become a
competitive thing where
one team that's planning on firing as
coach decides to pull the trigger a
couple weeks early so as not to fall
behind somebody else who's already
pulled that trigger
and it'll be interesting to see you know
the intention of it of course is to make
the hiring process a little bit less
rushed
and you know give more candidates a
chance to
to interview um you know so like teams
are able to make more thorough decisions
rather than it being pure speed dating
um
you know and and and i think that that
part of it's good but you know i
absolutely think there's a possibility
that this does lead to teams pulling the
trigger a little earlier than they would
have planned otherwise albert prior here
on the rich eisen show and you just gave
me a list of places where coaches might
uh be on the way out and franchises
making a change what's the situation
with jacksonville right now at this
owner's meeting that you can tell albert
no i um i still think it's tbd um you
know i think shod khan's obviously been
very very uh impatient with coaches over
the years uh gus bradley got four years
doug marone got four years
you know and i think this has got to be
something where shot khan takes the
temperature of his building
and
you know i think you go one of two ways
and i don't know there's any other way
to go you either move on from urban
meyer after this year or
you
decide that you're going to double down
on him and that's going to have to
include
like changes on his staff and him
bringing in guys that
like that he can work with because
clearly
you know and tom pelissera did a great
job you know reporting that stuff out
for you guys um you know like i i think
it's pretty clear
that that building isn't walking in
lockstep right now or else these sorts
of stories don't get out and i've heard
some of this stuff too
um so like you either
have to move on from urban and make that
difficult decision and probably write
some pretty big checks or
you have to double down on urban and go
and get guys that are i guess more in
line with the way that he does things
and give it another go in 2022. it's
like i said i don't think any sort of
final decision has been made on anything
quite yet on it but um you know those
two just those two
i mean if you'd asked
10 11 months
ago you know what would your reaction be
if these are your two options in
december um he probably wouldn't be very
happy about that no of course not
certainly with trevor lawrence you know
hanging in the balance and his career
and and one of the greatest prospects
that college has sent to the next level
or the fact that jacksonville had
dropped you know um in in their laps
they earned obviously with their play
last year but you know you mentioned
right there the way that urban does
things that's doing a heavy lift right
there because that assumes that it still
works in the professional ranks because
you know the stories that you hear about
how he challenged his coaches and things
like that is exactly the stuff that he
would do at ohio state that's exactly
the stuff that that might be happening
behind the scenes and players buckeyes
would never dare go across the field and
chit-chat with you know
michigan or penn staters or michigan
state are saying you have no idea what's
going on around here like that the
jaguars did with the rams that's the
difference between college and
professional ranks so the question is is
what
can he
change his reaction to losing because
the way that he reacted in the preseason
and throughout this season through the
tom pelicero quotes you can't do that in
the nfl when you're gonna lose sometimes
more more than let's just say once every
two years like he used to in college
right i mean is that a fair question
honestly yeah i mean quite honestly it
was the question i think coming into the
year
um was is it gonna is the way he does
things gonna translate and how is he
gonna handle losing he's already lost
two more games in jacksonville they did
in seven years at ohio state
and you know we've all seen you know and
and everybody's seen it the way he
reacts you know with the way he reacted
to losses at florida the way he reacted
to losses at ohio state there's this
very serious question like can you
handle
you know
can you handle a league where
you know if you go 11 and six like
that's losing six times in a year but
that's a really good year and if you're
going and going to jacksonville that'd
be a 10-win improvement you know what i
mean like so i think that's been a
management of failure i think was always
going to be a big question
you know and then i think like with this
program
um you know like kind of being able to
cross over to the pros this is such an
interesting thing because
i think like so much of you know what he
was able to do and the way he was able
to get people to work
um at ohio state was like it was all it
was like testimony it was it was a truth
over testimony you know it was like if i
if you follow what i'm doing we're going
to win huge and everybody's going to get
rich right like so like can he push
people the same way when maybe it's
taking a little longer to get those
results in the pros
i mean
you know this as well as i do rich it's
a lot harder to push guys in the pros
that way if you're not giving them
immediate results because everybody's
job is on the line every day of the week
and so
that to me is going to be an interesting
thing you know to follow here over the
next couple of weeks presuming he
survives the week
um and like where that building is
going forward especially with such a
like just such a
i would say
like
they're they're they're
just there should be urgency there to
make sure
that you've got your young quarterback
in the right spot and with the right
people and you know that leads to a
bunch of big box questions that shot
khan's got to answer what's the sense
there what are people saying i mean
again that's again this is a scuttlebutt
uh uh industry that we're in what is it
walking around that building right there
that all right
so like here's what's interesting is
i i think urban has determined i
apologize for the win
texas um i i like the sense that i've
got is that urban feels like there are a
number of weak links on his coaching
staff
and
he's responsible for that because he
hired those guys
and generally what he would do um in his
previous stops when you know that was
there
is you know he'd get guys in a room and
he'd basically say what have you done
for me lately what are you doing to make
us better today and he challenged guys
and in a way it was the guys who knew
maybe they weren't doing enough
would feel uncomfortable and eventually
they'd get weeded out and i'm not saying
it's the right way to do things but
it took like a certain type of coach to
survive in that fire
and quite frankly
your coaches probably aren't talking to
the media the same way they do in the
[ __ ] you know what i mean like so
that's a piece of it too
and um you know again like it's just
you know you you look at where they are
and like i've heard they basically urban
has basically left the defensive staff
alone like they don't like they don't
have like there's not an issue there
with him and defensive coaches they do
their thing he thinks they've done a
good job they're left alone
i think like the questions are going to
are right there with that offensive
staff and you even wonder like you look
at this right and so you know does daryl
bevel survive does brian shot and ever
survived do the position coaches survive
especially when
like his old offensive coordinator from
florida and utah dan mullen is sitting
out there maybe wanting to get in the
nfl
so
like i i just like there's it's
there's so much like there's so many big
decisions that need to be made here
and again like hanging in the balance is
a generational quarterback prospect the
best quarterback
is
andrew luck and a guy who has been held
in that scene that luck elway manning
sort of category
again like it's just
i think the question of your shot is
like do you trust that urban is going to
get it right with our young quarterback
or
do you say i don't want to miss out on
getting like a josh mcdaniels with with
with trevor lawrence now i i again i
can't say enough like these are big box
decisions for the owner of the jaguars
he's not used to having to make them
this quickly because generally the
issues in his organization whether it
was when gus was the coach when doug was
the coach generally aren't this high
profile and
haven't been anywhere near this volatile
nor nor could he possibly lose a
candidate to replace them um during the
season because you weren't allowed to
talk to candidates during the season and
other teams might get a head start on
those folks i mean so the clock's
ticking literally right now not a month
right
i believe they play i believe they play
houston this week right um
the jacksonville jaguars
yeah i think they do houston
so
what happens if you lose like in a in a
big way to houston you know oh my god
like like week one like week one i think
yeah i mean i think you have to like i
think they
beyond just winning like i think they
have to show like if i'm shot khan like
you're looking for real signs of life
this week that's what you you want to
see an engaged team you want to see
until you see a team that's going out
there with something to prove
i mean if they look like if it sort of
looks dead fish again like it did last
week
i mean i think that you know obviously
would bring in another set of questions
albert thanks for the call get out of
the wind go get some more information
greatly appreciate it we'll chat soon
all right thanks rachel that's albert
pereira at albert breer on on twitter i
follow him you should as well hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here